all right so some things I'm trying to
do is wait so mid-foot back then
centerline stays on that way foot goes
out shift my weight bring the toes maybe
the toes now I'm going to put on this
side
I don't relationships my ankle key and
get that this hip turns my foot is gone
in not consciously and you're doing this
make sure you don't drill up you want to
drill it down should be moving
my feet are under my gifts will depress
feet on the - okay when I go to turn I
come and I turn this this but watch this
disconnecting Clippers in a market Lyon
sound fascist okay should be here
[Music]
so I have to do spinal displacement so
if you take the grip away right this is
what I would see okay so what you're
trying to learn here is is he pushes
that don't let it get close don't try to
go ahead a bit slow it down do zero so
he has a push you're not pulling not
going plus negative or plus plus you
push this and you utilize this whole
situation I am contributing to the
conflict here by maintaining my ground
what I'm going to do is to see pushes i
neutralize by moving the same amount
that he moved in in terms of the trip so
I'm going to walk those hips to his
pressure
his pressure by hip movement basically
me I'm just fully whatever
[Music]
I'm holding this I'm pushy pushy
the reason why there's energy and power
and conflict here if I match his energy
there's no it's more force there right
I'm trying to go positive I don't want
to go negative either
I just match it okay and what we're
doing here is I will step so far he
pushes I'll step so far and then the
rest I'm going to school you see how I'm
doing that okay then I treat so from the
grid here
that's me contesting that's regenerating
the conflict not him us so he pushes I
absorb and
if you pay attention on the school what
it does is the left hand is yielding so
what is the right hander
it's coming into the technique seen ah
so it does not have the same Julian
spirit it has an Oscar so let's try you
don't